and we are live yes all the words right
out of your mouth last point number 26
this is like 25.5%
yes in case they've got some crazy stuff
on Thursdays 12 but we gots a reveal
stream to cover just as before we kind
of enjoy doing the live reactions with
you guys so combat reveal stream went
live I peaked Twitter I shouldn't know
but I saw like one thing but honestly I
think there's a lot of stuff that we're
gonna look into between any subclasses
or weapon mods and time to kills and
things like that so this is what we're
gonna be covering so if you guys want to
tune in for our live reactions and
discussions we're going to play back the
archive video we don't have the best way
to do this so we're honestly going to be
hitting pause in the video talking about
things that we see and then starting to
back up again so bear with us if our
time sinks are a little off and we have
a second on those but mostly we are here
to go through the reveal stream get our
live reactions and discuss everything as
we go yeah I mean this is for me
presents give you a little quick
backstory just yeah for me this is one
of my personal streams that I've been
looking for this is very important to me
I want to see how they handle this I
want to obviously be heard about the
three taps and all that stuff but um
yeah I'm coming in completely blind um
you know vampire waking up and getting
excited so bear with us but we're gonna
do this thing
simultaneous all right so I'm gonna
stream up I'm on 57 seconds that's where
I'm down we'll go three two one play
kind of in that sequence we're gonna
watch it live so basically just if you
need it pause it just hit spacebar works
for me and all around pause and talk so
anything you see just say pause and
we'll go as we go just like we did
before nope you guys are gonna enjoy the
ride with us if you haven't seen it yet
or if you guys are just gonna join chat
leave comments afterwards let us know
your thoughts and everything but if
you're in chat and you've already seen
it yeah wait till we get to that part
yeah okay no countdown going to start
this countdown on screen in five four
three two one play
fifteen I could 54 53 52 51 50 my early
yeah I need a second pause yeah you did
you go now five over 42 or 43 how close
are we now
I'm at Oh 14 so 11 12 with what wait
what are you counting down from I'm at
our level spelling the video and 14
seconds from vessels prompt style suit I
met I meant okay so I jumped ahead some
at five seconds okay oh my god yeah yeah
so if you hit play let me know when
you're at five and I'll hit start cool
sorry guys this is a knuckle most
Orthodox way to do this but we apologize
all right seven six five okay playing
cool all right when you said five I was
in play here we go no videos have been
done this week yet so weekly reset comes
next
I always loved in music
no no Oh fantastic no teen luggage
powers all right we've seen this you
know yes we've seen the infamous story
tap
let's go boom boom good morning and
what's the home is from twitch or
YouTube welcome to Bungie TV I'm deej
and I'll be your host for this combat
reveals dream I'd like to introduce you
to my co-hosts who are designers from
our sandbox team it's true this is true
good morning I want good morning very
good how are you good glad to have all
three of you here let's begin with mr.
Josh Hamrick Sam Urick uh hi what do you
want I want to know what you do a budget
oh I do I drink some coffee yeah and I
go to meetings and I try and keep these
guys happy and on task which is really a
struggle now I know what I'm mo model so
I did real work for like a very limited
or run yeah what claud's Kilimanjaro
hello
taking a break from your honeymoon so
much about the state of combat in year
two that he is actually taking a break
from his honeymoon and arrived on set
ten whole minutes ago rehearsed what did
you have for breakfast Oh what's your
specialty at Bungie on the sandbox
design team so I'm sandbox designer I
work on the abilities team basically
making all these supers on me perks that
was how you you did a good job i'm so
hype down and Greg Peng how's it going
good glad to have you in one of the hot
seats talk to us about your role on the
sandbox design team and your specific
contributions to the state of combat in
the second year of Destiny - yeah pretty
much all the Forsaken weapons have gone
through my hand in some way sometimes
I'll just poke at a little bit though
but uh yeah the sandbox designer working
on weapons all right what we're going to
do today is we're gonna talk about how
the arrival of Destiny to Forsaken and
the beginning of year two is gonna
change the way we all fight
the changes in weapon balance the
changes in abilities the some of the new
features that will allow you to
configure the way you play are gonna be
available to all players of destiny to
some of these changes will even arrive
before Forsaken on August 28th and what
we want to do is give you a pre mission
briefing so that you can start thinking
right now about how you might be
configuring your guardian so that it's a
good reflection of how you are as a
player with that Josh talk to me a
little bit about what are the
overarching goals when you take a look
at destiny two year two what were your
goals in approaching the work that you
and your team did together to make a new
combat meta yeah I think we you know we
looked at with hood at year one and saw
what people were were saying and
thinking and how the game was being
played and kind of you know what what we
were seeing happen with the game and so
we came out of it with one thing we
wanted to do is give more give players
more options for them to specifically
tweaked and tuned their loadout to play
the way they want to play I'm front
lines I'm in the air quite a bit right
now I want I play for speed and
efficiency yeah which means a dialogue
but in those regards like I wanted tools
to be able to tweak that place down to
play the way I play right what you call
a race a specific role exactly in the in
combat versus clock who plays poorly and
slow Wow
yeah so he has give us i play poorly and
slow but mostly who's gonna balk yeah
I'm a support player I love my riff
everybody gets a little gun buddy over
there why it's a waste we wanted we
wanted the game to be interesting for
longer and so that means things like the
drops you're getting we want it to be
special and fun you know every time you
see something hit your screen you want
to be what is that right we want to
bring that that moment back and has
better Devils if you will
exactly oh the best demo it was it could
be and then as well the kind of doing
the same thing with the meta we didn't
the meta to get still as quickly and so
one of the nice things those kind of
work in concert so if you deliver one
then the you know the meta stays fresh
for longer because everybody's rotating
through different things more players
discover the perfect combination of
these different elements the more they
may shift their fighting styles exactly
and because it's a long smooth it slowly
changes the landscape over time and then
the last huge thing huge and the thing
we'll talk about most today is we wanted
to bring back even more hero moments and
doing that specifically through
increased skill gap like we wanted to to
make the game not harder to play but
certainly we wanted to make the game in
the right hands be special and and you
know insane to watch right we wanted we
wanted the people who are who are best
at the game to shine and for people to
look at those people and say like I
don't want in both in the way that the
tweets they mode to the load-out the
abilities they're choosing to run the
armor they're choosing to run the
weapons they're choosing to run and just
the the way that they play the game so
yeah now Claude we have how many new
supers in 1490 versa so basically we
wanted to add a lot more variety to the
way you can customize your existing
subclasses because we felt like we
wanted to make everyone have a new way
to play basically that was their main
goal and so we added new supers and
associated perks for each of those
papers but oldest players do not join us
in the tangled Shore for this new
adventure in forsaken but we certainly
hope that you do but if you just come
along with us into the adventures of
year 2 without being a player of
forsaken they're still gonna find some
changes to the existing subclasses that
they know and love yeah it basically
meant that lethality was gonna change as
well and so abilities needed to react to
all the weapon changes and so that you
could have a lot of viable options to
counter a player you miss coming at you
with guns that are more lethal as well
so goodnight changed supers had to get
more reliable in a bunch of different
ways and so I was faster and so we
looked at
the ones that are underperforming
currently bumping that like I said
relative to the newsstand ostracize
weekly here and there yep into a lot of
the existing perks and may liabilities
and grenades and stuff got changed to
help diac tolerance lethality fingers
will see a lot I'm having your evidence
of those don't mention we actually take
to the parole for a live fire actually
talk about a man that knows his craft
and not a single moment of rehearsal
stomach full of cake heart full of love
okay so Greg we're you're doing a lot of
telling a lot of talking about how we
changed the sandbox
let's show them shall we yeah do it you
have a controller in your hand you're
going to be the driver and we have a
warlock a bus run and that your warlock
[ __ ] no it is not my warlock say I love
that arm right similar mama Lily this is
a dev environment so I'm doppelganger
for those of you watching you know you
might see some things that you won't
completely understand you'll see some
things that aren't completely unfinished
you might even see some you know
elements of the UI either here or in
game that might not look entirely
finished but that's what we do when we
bring you into our creative process so
great so what's different yeah I started
out by tossing value slaughter we still
have the three slot system kinetic
energy and power yep
so the paradigm still lies that you know
kinetic weapons going in the first slot
right grenade energy type weapons I can
slot and power weapons go in the third
slot mm-hmm however you'll notice that
next to the light level of weapon now
that type of weapon not as primary yeah
or special mm-hmm or heavy so basically
what we've done is we've turned what
ammo a weapon taste into an attribute of
the weapon rather than tying it to the
slaw which means that in the kinetic
slot we can run both primary and special
weapons the same with the energy slot
let's see how they move and the heaviest
dragons around sorry in the power sight
you can only run heavy slow heavy
weapons yep so I love her all night
take a look an old having this lovely
array of weapons we have here here we
have a shotgun here we have a hand
cannon a bow a bow is also going to be a
primary weapon mm-hmm brand new
archetype for players of forsaken
fulfilling varieties of better Devils
here
pulse rifle sniper rifle and here in the
energy slot we have also shotguns those
snipers and not featured here in fusion
rifles as well ladies also trace rifles
we actually upgraded trace rivals to a
special ammo which means that they will
be doing more damage in your jiske no
clumb so here in the interesting in the
power slot we have grenade launchers we
have all grenade launchers
no actually we've also created or we've
also changed some of these single
shotgun a launchers into using yeah that
would make sense a different damage
someone had a grenade launchers and did
you yes you touch them - yes it
appropriate they will fit appropriately
yeah
rocket launchers swords and linear
fusion rifles so it's not just a matter
of you know crazy free-for-all just use
any weapon in a slot you've curated this
you've taken a look at this from a
perspective of how can we still create
all gonna be an awesome balance and so
Klaus is giving us more options is that
kind of an accurate summary of how the
weapon slots are changing absolutely I
mean wait
but if you're crazy if you're crazy you
can broke free shot and sure can orders
are not just that's right there there
are a couple a couple of roles like that
that you can run three weapons with so
this the flow of ammunition on the
battlefield has always been one of the
ways that we've been able
to kind of control the flow of combat
and how these fights spin out in real
time how is that changing in year two or
how have these new design decisions
impacted the way that works yeah so what
we found is like we we knew we wanted to
change slots like we heard all the
feedback we ourselves have been playing
with it what we didn't want to do was
just roll back like we felt like we
could do something more interesting yeah
what you're getting to see here today
and we're super happy with the way that
this started to play well we realized in
a hurry Oh was that the weapon ammo
model was certainly going to have to
change to support this and then later as
we'll talk about that also rolls right
downhill into then that needs to change
lethality as well and then lethality
rolls further downhill and that means
that needs to change abilities etc etc
which will cover all today as far as
that ammo model goes though what we
realized was we we wanted to we wanted
to support players actually playing the
way they want to play but don't we
didn't want to make a promise and then
say like but you can't really do it
right like you're super special
circumstances for sure if you play three
of the same weapon or even two specials
you're gonna have a harder time on your
hands keeping ammo in right if you are
running dual primaries which is
obviously the easiest thing to keep both
ammo but then the gaben will feed you
fine if you're running a d1 style loader
or or a mirror do you want style it out
but the cool thing is that as long as
you're like for example in PvP which
we'll show you in just a little bit you
do respawn with ammo including special
ammo and so you're always being fed ammo
to keep you playing and so even in the
case of running dual specials like
you're gonna be in the game you're gonna
be playing you're gonna be able to do
stuff in out faster if you die you get
in being able to run my words PB maximum
special weapons and heavy weapons away
jungle stay afloat like they do Greg I
can see that on this specific character
you've got some duplicates of the same
weapon I do why would you do that well
I'd be without previously random roles
are back Randy Davis yeah
you don't know the definition of the
word menagerie look it up it's fun then
moment outlaw hackable mag steady round
and meet fights now this filter Hurst
actually it's not it's not rehearse that
joking it live here this pretty spicy
also that go mad and city runs you know
what I think I think I have a five is
back and the crossfire oh yeah no perks
I that holds that there has been red
balloons fine the back that's every time
a better Devils drops in the crucible
it's gonna have a different role it
could be a better day
yeah it could be we have this thing here
which is the master work so of course
now previous masters just some went from
one to five so you have basically
somewhat of like a five percent bonus at
the max yep we have now made massive
work go all the way to ten for weapons
for one day but okay so which means that
you can actually get a 10% range boost
on this better Devils if you level it up
ganda you can even even better than you
even better
imagine it's a it's a ten-point scale
and you can upgrade it and upgrade it
keep on going yep keep on going but
where's the visual indicator watch it
all right it's working I was literally
just inside when you're grading ranges
yes are you asking us what are you yeah
I'm wondering if it's play from this
weapon 70 like the ten tears are their
names like their one tear phonons
there's a subset of stats that you can
master work range stability handling
reload
we actually so because we're going
through a more of a leveling type system
now we moved the magazine mass work to
now it is a mod which I will show you
next is the new and improved
matza like yeah like old trackers oh
wait what's this hand you can clean them
shoes give you great so will you love me
a train so here we have the empty mod
socket oh and as you can see the damage
like mods are gone however we've
replaced it with this plethora of
drastically it Chris Curti are actually
gonna have attack attacked on the way
you're fine exactly you know we've
talked about and we're excited about the
legacy those are the bugs like you can
apply yeah all all things to to make the
gameplay a little more the way that you
play and how do i acquire these mom
that's a lot of customers the two below
the matzo line 11 however you're like oh
but how am I gonna get them out of the
weapon once there is a weapon oh that's
great Wow
tell us grant so here we have that
pretty good doubles with the major spec
mod on it and I will shard it dismantle
it you hold there is the major spec mod
there
I'll take a tank and you can use it so
you come get a random roll do you like
this isn't okay all I'm gonna keep it
you can get a weapon with the role that
you like this isn't as good but it had a
model that I had a mod I like I'm nice
man to live my eco I like you that's
cool we all use different words for
dismantling weapons he shards you nuke
yeah very powerful it's extreme it's all
the same activity though
alright now let's see let me take a look
for some roles perks possibly anything
else you want to cover about the weapons
specifically I'm at thirty twelve blow
it off yeah this is yeah like random
roles perks and mods anything twelve
okay so this is interested man what do
you think I'm gonna get your thoughts
version um so the master work if there
are ten tears but it's the same little
bump is before that's kind of making it
unnecessarily longer personally yes the
mod slots I'm digging some more driving
mods the mods that actually change
bosses or counterbalance that you can
pick and I still want to know what the
208th are but you can add another one on
so I guess that's your incentive to
master work cuz you're given that you
then get that extra slot right so
basically what they're trying to do is
this I guess what part of what they were
talking about earlier with leveling and
growing with your weapon kind of a deal
so basically the vibe I'm the critical
involve I'm getting is that 10% a week
or 5% whatever it is that we currently
get now you have to now level up to that
but once you level up to that that it
looks like you unlock more perks on the
gun seems like and yeah and then you
then like I said you have that custom
customization however if one of the mods
that you initially put on that weapon
you know I'm saying you really like but
you don't necessarily care for the role
of the weapon you can then shard it and
then keep that mod which is very cool
because it's gonna be times where it's
like wow I really like this mod that
does more impact or you know the mod
that gives me you know
Icarus with air accuracy but I don't
really care for the weapon right you
know breaking that that that's a big
deal I'm saying that dad that's actually
because now you're really gonna the mods
gonna have real importance man like if
you especially if you like certain ones
and you want to put that on specific
weapons this is cool this is cool at
first I thought they were just
artificially extending the master work
thing but once I've seen once you level
up and what you get it's almost acting
like a catalyst once you unlock it right
yeah it's kind of a can gives another
extra little slide and I guess you got
two other below it maybe I still don't
know what those are little my so my
question though is it might work on my
better devils and I get one and I put
all my master I think okay this is it's
solid it's good for PvP I'm gonna use
this then I get a new one but I've
already leveled this thing up to ten and
I don't have that many cores if I break
this thing down am I gonna get some of
my cores back these are about the master
core itself yeah the cores and I spin to
level it up ya know when I saw this
short one I sort of breakdown I didn't
see any um I don't know if it broke down
a master work though that's one that is
that's like and that's questions things
where if you put the time in maybe you
won't get them all back but if you'll
get you know I mean it looked like quite
a few cores like 15 cores or something
like that I don't know if you get but I
would hate to dump 15 corals at it I
mean I've been playing a little more
I've been playing like as much as some
people I'm playing a little more but I
still only have looking at my inventory
I have a hundred eleven master of course
oh well yeah as I have a decent amount
but if it's 15 port gun and you're gonna
have a random rolls and builds like
those are gonna be gone real fast so
yeah so they either don't have to be we
have to change the drop rate all those
let's see yeah the other question you're
not gonna be getting master work drops
cuz you're gonna level up so where the
course can come from that's a good
question we have to find out the source
of the cores now no that's a great
question so lots of questions
continually so alright ready to start
this thing back up in three two one go
else you want to cover about the weapons
specifically that seems like it runs the
gamut yeah
[Music]
yeah okay make make your customization
deeper but also make the game a little
bit simpler to understand how many
objects I'm shocked that loot drops
gonna be more interesting over time the
combat medic can evolve and change over
time as people discover more interesting
combinations this looks promising when
you make change you make this to
anything in destiny we've got this crazy
sandbox that impacts a menagerie of
activities I use this new weapon system
on everything run a final raid boss tool
in ER the people that they meet in the
crew want to see them attacked every
other system in the game like others
like if the game organism if I give you
a bigger heart you're gonna need a robe
more robust circulatory system so like
translate a metaphor like that into the
work you do when you start playing
around with weapon slots and when you
start playing around with ammunition
flow and different perks to make people
more lethal how does that impact
everything what else what other changes
did you have to make in order to keep up
yeah it's kind of surprising the amount
of things that touch touches when you
start to change it so we like I said we
started with slots we knew we want to
change it so we changed that and we got
ourselves into a position where it was
okay we are there live either effect
ammo well we got to build any ounces
they don't immediately return no system
to work with people have enough uptime
because my family that you know or
Windows the right cost so we gave out
more ammo we gave you more room for
those special weapons that I got I was
seeing a lot of very tough and then that
means those who don't have specialisms
are suddenly dead to rights all the time
right I'm hoping for stuff like this
they might be able to modulate their
lethality and so we you know we push
down this road we got to that point we
realized like we've got to get more in
all of the
this is right there if we just are
delivering on this it's gonna be great
it's gonna be the thing that we promised
it would be able to be enjoyable yeah
but that means making a call to go ahead
and change lethality and so Greg was
like hey I got an idea
I'm gonna I'm gonna slam up precision
damage and let's see how that plays and
we're like okay let's do it
check it yeah let's go for it and so he
checked it in and we played it and you
know it's it's been tweeted a lot since
then as Greg can talk about but the idea
totally worked
right we're like oh yeah this is this is
better this is what we need I like to
play with an auto rifle or if someone
out there likes to play with a hand
cannon and all of a sudden we've got all
these shotguns and all these grenade
launchers moving further up into the
weapon slots where you're gonna see them
more often I'm not just gonna get
overrun and now my auto rifles worthless
no but you're putting the requirement on
me to evolve I now have to embrace
precision fighting because I'll tell you
I don't you know like what do we say
before we play we play slow and bad and
dumb we don't take our time we take my
time I get it right I aim for center
mass there's more to hit there so in
order to have the greater time to kill
it's it's about it is or you play smart
I really like the detail system and I
want to run to Hank and yeah and in some
version of a sniper right and so again
by pushing that lethality up it makes
that totally possible like I play fine
and in fact I never run ammo and it's
amazing all right and just play forever
yeah and so like being able to do all
this play styles but then guys I think
you're leading to that then starts to
show through in other ways we're like
now the guns are awesome and when I run
up to somebody and give them a high-five
when I was trying to punch them in the
face that suddenly does not so good so
so across the entire spectrum of space
magic and clawed abilities whether it's
melees or supers or what have you when
you took a look at this new sandbox what
changes did you feel needed to be made
to all players not just renew that they
can show this is any player that has
their favorite super or has their
favorite melee
what did you feel needed to be done in
order to kind of bring that stuff into
balance with everything else that was
exciting and shiny and new and more
powerful yeah I think like like Marvel
draft is saying like we will make these
changes and little will have ideas about
how about a workout like what things
will change down the line we need to
play it at the end of the day so we'll
get it in the lab we'll play it every
day over and over and over again and
then we just think about like what
decisions are we making as a player like
someone's rushing here the shotgun I'm
like when do i what can I do and if
those decisions are feeling shallow like
I don't have it like I just die then
that doesn't feel great and so we start
touching other weapons so then it still
feels a little bit more shallow than we
wanted to we look at other options and
so in particular the I would say they're
probably the biggest change to the
neutral game of the abilities just like
non supers basically is we make we went
back to two pit melees so - oh gosh
three shots to the otic lot more hectic
fast-paced combat and so once we have to
- hit me like a lot of things that
already exist we're sort of tuned around
to hit melee before you go and this like
I think that's an excellent example of
as you think everybody can start to see
like every decision we make like even a
lot of that you can predict right but
it's like if we do this that means we're
selling doing this right if we do that
are we gonna have to do this and so we
play it to find out because you don't
sometimes you surprise you you're like
no it turns out this is fine okay
sometimes we won't find it like it's a
risk
yeah it's worth taking and so when we
change to hit may like we like the
approach and then end up changing than
when club's going next time you're
finished tell me there's a bunch of
stuff like and DT launch that we tuned
around the whole three hit melee model
where we said nothing would instantly
evaporate you but in a to hit melee
world there needs to be some power
spikes and those power spike started to
become things like shoulder cards again
so all the shoulder cards mechanics oh
yeah hammers drank all the ones that are
basically you got a third person you
punch someone
those are gonna now one hit yes it's
back yeah the previous place
so happy about the way you and your
warlock whiners and punches needed
moments like Nate Lee Boyd walkers
charged grenades also dealing more
damage now for instance yeah basically
any night was promising damage increases
we need to re-evaluate in this new world
of lethality yeah and then my personal
favorite we haven't touched on we've
only teased a little bit is its tether
yeah yeah so that's the change become
more reliable in this new world as well
and so we deep though so we had a bunch
of ideas what we could do with the night
stocker in general for some of the
feedback we've gotten around hot shadows
shot is unreliable and we wanted to
evaluate them in sequence and one of the
things that we found pretty early on was
that tether actually isn't as reliable
as it needs to be you know it's not
finding guys is frequently like people
are passing through it they're not
getting tethered fast enough that kind
of thing yeah and so we basically
normally to increase the I'll call
search frequency you know the tether can
activate on so now it's like would you
do the Golden Gun
you found all the stuff that's good got
a little bit more time so in this new
world of fast we want you have the
ability to sort of yet more carefully
choose your targets so he gave all
Golden Gun versions a couple more
seconds literally two more seconds well
run around with all golden no solution
evaporate guys
similarly throwing knife came up and
damage to match than you to hit melee
world okay that's a good nice I think
the best of the work that you've done
and you can call it out when you see it
can be found in a live-fire exercise ya
know so we're gonna go there right now
we're going on a model - yes
cause now I'm at 30 not 12 with Kosmos
rates 39:13 so we're gonna go there
right go sorry we don't go paused okay
all right
looking at Cosmo and Kevin yes I love
the final boss t-shirt salesman
I love Cosmo face right now in my skirt
so there are some tweaks yes I first of
all on stream I need an apology I've had
to hear it for mops they're not gonna do
it is that gonna be a time it's gonna be
just a do see everybody's gonna just use
new stuff and the other stuff is gonna
bring in the nose like oh that went on
say is there bring the lethality up
mm-hmm one of my questions is like okay
so I guess it's kind of like it depends
on what supers use and it sounds like to
hit the ones that people don't use that
much which is good because I run around
with hammers and I'm like okay but then
I see this lake monster hammer throwing
hammer like a flier thing right
my honestl honest worried was like some
was damage and that it sounds like
they're handling so yes I'm sorry I was
wrong fine that's all that's all you
wanted to hear you're a man of your word
all right on the other side which um I
think some of the new ones just seemed
cooler so I feel like there are some
things where if they make them a little
snazzier like I mean the tethered me an
instant is a huge thing for pee pee I
know but in PDE the faster you can save
your own butt is gonna be huge - yeah so
it's the tether speed your warlocks are
getting some love got some filing collar
that was huge that was young because
some storm caller as it currently sits
you can literally weigh 75 percent of
your trance and just barely get the
yellow bar down oh I know oh I hate how
in PvE especially stars like all sickle
you are you are you same thing Willett
ality in PvP it's like it's not quick
enough so that people can get away
you really destroyed its it's just it's
it's not that effective so it's good
like I said for them to go back not like
I completely agree what you said the new
ones look cooler and it's new it's shiny
wanna touch me honestly but I guess I'm
just so glad that they went back and it
was funny these with them two of the
biggest buffs I my opinion they needed
to happen were hunter and in that war
like okay you know I'm the last request
mostly cuz I'm not gonna every patch
known everything right now on this I
mean the only request I'm hoping for is
dorm play and I know that in the new
mods will help link up tree which is all
about being the air and having you
needing inner accuracy to get you know
stuff back and it's a cool build
universe a in theory on paper right but
we have some monsters like but I still
want to see if they did anything else
because the bottom tree dorm blade is
just superior you know I'm saying like
it's not even it's not even close so
this is really cool the overall from
what we've heard so far and we know that
I guess it when it comes to things like
this it's generally a bigger list of
packed notes and improvements for each
day yes so they're just given us you
know this minor version of probably the
highest complaint stuff Lucy but I'm
excited I'm excited seems like and then
the other side of it too is when you
think of the perks on the trees some of
those that I feel may need buffs as
you're saying I'm kind of curious where
those are gonna fall and we'll have to
see the patch notes and stuff but some
of the newer perks seemed notice Lee
much more specifically beneficial to
like a certain super it's like so they
asked how are you gonna tweak if you
have the storm collar like coming home
a-ha and that's got its only single
option are there might be two for the
ads like those are some more the pieces
i want to see to know is the new option
just gonna be badass because it's only
got one is the old one that both trees
are kind as you're saying mediocre some
need some help like some things still
need a little of the perk trees again
we'll have to see but but one last
comment before we start back we also
have to keep in mind when we look
through those marks right the mods now
that customization now ties into the
super cuz remember we saw stuff like
let's just say you know i'm
still dissatisfied which don't call it
lethality right I can start building
weapons right that now I saw stuff that
said like against major bosses against
me cools you I'm saying to even further
increase my ballot I think that's cool
that you can almost have like a PvE
build mod yeah I mean that's gonna be
damage of that weapon it's not gonna
affect your super dad yeah yes I mean if
they say buff you're super on the mud
then hell yeah bring it on you know I
guess I got caught up with um
inner accuracy for a little bit you know
yeah like that hand cannon would be
better if you switch to your Scout
that's gone into it alright we'll get it
going in three two one go to Cosmo
friendly neighborhood community manager
and Kevin Yanis gentleman real quick
introduce yourselves to our stream
audience talk about what you do at
Bungie and then we'll go and we'll take
a look at all of those triangles on our
walls that we designer here I work on
game modes ammo system ranks things that
everyone cares about I'm here to talk to
you about weapons I'm Cosmo community
manager I am in charge of taking all of
your feedback right in the 12 and
telling you new things that's coming to
destiny alright gentlemen
so let's uh go take a look at a brand
new crucible map you guys have touched
down on destination and this is an
educational ceasefire of what would you
like to do in order to help us with a
little proof of concept before we
actually get into the fight yes so we're
gonna we're gonna it slow can
demonstrate some of the time-to-kill
changes here Cosmo and I have picked up
Hank load idea to represent archetypes
I'm running like a aggressive pulse
rifle and a nice rapid fire scout right
yes you're having Scouter double primary
in this week and you load it down with a
periscope ammo there well I picks them
up yeah but just say you did alright
let's shoot some people all right sure
yeah I'll start with this uh aggressive
pulse as you can see here a to burst Oh
almost anymore hmm and then with this
rabbit Fire Scout five shots to the head
and gone mm-hmm as you see here he
dropped his special ammo oh how about
yourself mr. Cosmo man all right got
this nice assault rifle hmm pretty fast
time two and three that was real body
one has two body with him that's like so
worried well we get into the fight
unless there's anything else you want to
show us that point-blank
yeah why don't you guys go into your
build and configure yourselves come on
let me see your arm super couple of
exhibition matches and they will talk to
our friends who are watching from home
or wherever they are Mermoz by the way
that way exactly what role you want to
play in combat so I'm gonna I'm gonna
run a double primary built here and I'm
gonna be running a new weapon windows
how and I'm gonna run see Oh actually
see okay there's a frame I composite on
later yeah all right so I got this
better Devils that uh got a pretty
pretty good roll on out bad Landers
shotgun in my second slide shot and I
got this box you might recognize from a
little video we showed out shooting the
two rockets hey Cosmo I noticed that
you're running Icarus on you one frame
it or made a little bit later yeah so I
got the the Icarus so as you can see
when I jump but uh that aimer stays
pretty tired right it's smaller when he
jumps yep
the perfect tool still needs to be in
the hands of we're ready to fight we're
ready to fight alright then game on to
your corners let's try that again
alright we are in combat our combatants
are muted we're gonna listen to the
designers and gentlemen when when you
see a product of your labor something
you're proud of
you're excited about let's call it out
this is why we're fighting today
understand how better our three range to
learn about well they did I was out that
day about it yeah yeah instead just
check through wall no nobody's there
this is what happens ventral blades but
I blinked yeah so did he he got me it's
a very interesting hand cannon that uh
Yanis is using right now precision
family handcannon about the devil's how
did we increase respawn oh you're
probably mentioning okay he's not like
tall so heavy spawns on that so he said
it's interesting that you we changed the
respawn in our private match to keep the
emphasis on actions and that's what I
was waiting to come back to life one of
the things one of those kind of things
we were talking about you know it's you
touch one thing it all breaks it all
changes and I know we haven't can tell
us a little bit where we ended up but it
was one of the things you're like oh
when you do this that also means you
know this the speed at which you can
take control points might have to change
to be that what you respawn my house man
that bow that builds a problem but away
wow gonna pursue them now player
feedback right it's almost unheard of
kill him before you do it oh that was
the I think that was done this is a
superhero I'd have to get off where's it
occurs
and Cam's gonna be leap over even better
the way we're hanging on a special mo is
you spawn with and when you die that's
searching well of course you spawn that
they say when you die you drop it
special City doesn't have a yeast where
they're just hold in hand teammates do
like someone's about to shoot a rocket
at you the wish was ended that's for
sure time to dust out those headed to
the Father
so guys start watching lanes for those
again visit back yet you still gotta
follow through and pick up that ammo
actually then we jumped out of the well
yeah one of the one of the big changes
there aren't crates for them in the
world and because they drop on the on
the corpses of all of your enemies it
means if you just randomly snap into a
crowd you just produce more special ammo
for his buddies and or made it extremely
hard for you to go good so thinking
about what you're doing it matters a lot
more coming ran into a rift earlier it's
like it's a good segue there so we also
talked baby bumped up the healing oh oh
good battles so soak a couple cool
things that's happening so he just
product falls execution which was one of
them unites lack of heard that let's he
go invisible when you get I said kill
while crafting and then while you're
invisible in that state you actually
build up speed bikes and now is using
wrong way to destroy this team that was
trying to handle on a healing area put
down by the dawn blade but they were
able to mount a resistance there I mean
usually if somebody runs into a room
with his super it's like we're all dead
yeah push back there the Dom blade heal
is extremely good it's extremely
effective and it also buffs through
damage as well so they were able to push
back and the holy brass that Thunder
crashes got there he goes Thunder
crashing sounds here no the other thing
yeah so healing rift came up the space
of healing rift is now a little bit more
effective and had to me right yeah oh
nice give it some more it takes too long
keeping errata fireplace we found that
now and the other thing is empowering
ripped off the gap up nice you not Buffy
assisted in damage so now we'll also
[ __ ] say oh cool basically it's gonna
it's gonna keep up with this new
lethality
now other things we haven't talked about
but Armour also receives random moles
additionally there are of course mods
that go into your armor there are some
new and some that you used to from year
1 including the ability regeneration
speeds of things those have also all
been buffed because for the same reason
leave they don't take 5 now as well so
all the rules have been removed there's
no like hey put this on when you're
wearing blue pants on the morning of
August is your grenade regeneration
speed whatever and you can you can push
it all the way up to 5 to give you I
believe we settled on up I will say at
least a 60% I think we've settled on
higher as well as I think if you if you
just run for them you get the same
there you go I can't
Wow it looks like the on the opposing
team right now there's a lot of open
convert ear grenade and see a grenade
that can actually heal your allies and
give them an over field of ball can you
do that
so you hold whatever you're gonna button
is so that's left bumper for default Nam
and you'll convert your name pretty
quickly into healing there it was blade
barrage mummer oh so that's some nice
feller hunter super you basically flip
into the air with the Golden Gun
what's the inference there exotic
weapons have set pork sets yes they they
do not have the ability to throw them on
all right they are fictional and windows
are extremely powerful and very
specifically curated by y'all yeah it
looks like Heaven's load out here is
formed all around getting information so
yeah he's using a sword to speak a
little bit so I was saying with some
events using wish handy to get know
behind walls but also beasts invisible
you can actually see you guys behind
walls the entire time as well Wow
okay you could be alive that's gonna
help you yes there's a lot more super
counterplay now that tons of snipers are
walking around yeah but I think with
special blaze you get a lot of options
where you can basically you can go into
stealth your super doesn't drain as fast
and you can see guys behind walls which
lets you pick your targets a little bit
more carefully so if you're a little
better than Kevin is whoa Wow all these
around corners will you'll pick your
targets a little more you don't have to
throw yourself you don't have to just
throw yourself on to a shotgun choice
are you a little bit better than Kevin
is I wouldn't take my time we're in the
cheap seats yeah you're gonna pay for
that and test I'm sure yeah what's the
worst that could happen
I think it's just having killing you and
then saying take time take your time
yeah so Thunder crash you can steer
quite heavily and basically it looks
like whoever was using that has learned
how to pilot quite well you could like
start it and pile it on the wall on fly
mug right before you actually even
Landis was that Nathan
when we started talking about the bow
you had said that well china kill gaps
here we go base magic machine guns Dafoe
might seem archaic but it's a patient's
weapon and a recision weapon and we're
seeing
despite the editorial commentary from
Claude we're seeing a lot of really good
patient precise work in the hands of mr.
Janos here with that that's certainly
not the way I fight but I can tell that
you know this time good weapon gonna
hand him somebody who's good with it and
give me fits
we've also seen I mean people play it as
a battle run with it as well were you my
Kevin actually has the lid out to do
that effectively where you run in you go
for the single shot head shot of the bow
and then you quick swap with you know
something like lucky pants for example
to pull out a hand cannon real fast and
got them before they can what was that
which did you say lucky pin lucky pants
okay is that a shipping name or is that
one of hours a year one pant if you will
for the winter
okay that helps with with the use of
hang time yeah I like to run those was a
really fast draw time and put a curse on
that so I can actually pull that kind of
move off midair gonna get shot and
that's what's really gonna love dinner
see what happens we can still play
warrior mode with above Jeff playing the
right stats and then there are some
pretty incredible exotic armor pieces
that go along with those as well man yep
the old exotics also really interesting
and relevant again no way that's really
exciting in particularly solar charge
for instance
Stan decides they're also now really
really amazing to think about using
because it'll give you an over field
that's gonna help protect you as you
come in for that one hit kill no knives
for days and asides finally makes the
new sub braces are really good with one
technique you feeling grenade setup for
the demo
sorry protocol where we've been using
with center crash and trying to remember
what that what new favorite loadout is
the pants right oh the annotate boards
yes or slide reflect legs yeah sigh
reflect we're gonna put you put the
increased one of the new armor mods that
we brought back new old mark armor mods
you put the increased turning while
sprinting so you're super agile I'm
gonna reflect incoming fire and as you
slide quick you know you're always right
now he's got the ballistic strike charge
and so every time he's in the air he's
gonna have the ability that's the one
mailee button and basically do a
miniature version of death from above
anytime and a many target that one
doesn't want shot kill so we made
something sync choices there we're like
a shoulder charge is a little bit more
risky you have to get really close and
you're you're sacrificing your
positioning a lot more I even get to be
able to pull it off
whereas the ballistics track you can be
disguised no one's coming from I can't
wait to use more frequently again in
destiny I gotta tell you and I love the
way with Sandy - yep so a couple of
observations this has been a really good
even match yeah I've had one team run
away with this observations from chat
right now every hunter in chat is
shaming me brutally for not knowing what
lucky par guilty as charged
you know I've tunnel vision from my own
ways I freshly arrived dr. Lupo is
asking if it's good and they're telling
them that so far looks like so far looks
like you guys did a good job and people
want to see what cosmos doing so I can
tell you that within two kills here
we're going to switch to the new here -
mr. Cosmo 23 and we will see how he
fares in battle but in batons our next
we're actually going to let people
change up their loadouts a little bit
let you see a different way to play and
so as you'll notice on this every time
every time he died and came back he was
always coming back with two shotgun
rounds here we go and we are in game
with a nice eight kills pretty
interesting
widening the skill gaps still a good
close match yeah nice time so well
fought to our in-studio combatants and
thank you very much let's take a look at
our brave fighters and gentlemen good
game thank you so much for playing how
do you want to configure your Guardians
for the second round of clash hmm think
I'm gonna switch off to the bow any-any
my trees within with enhanced target
acquisition for my sniper and my pulse
right Oh actually that's the perfect
loadout for you because you were having
trouble hitting things well for those
who like to take their time Golden Gun
now has more time string I need to say
it my time probably hurried up I'm in
Cosmo what are we gonna see from you in
the next fight I'm gonna go crazy a wolf
in bad land or shotgun and legend no
factories Wow shotgun lowdown talk to
you read about your shotgun mods and
your shotgun perks how are of these
shotguns gonna be behaving differently
in combat I guess you once you're locked
out on the fly without me without any
cost no radar yeah it's already pretty
good alright we ready to go we are go
for launch that one request when you get
in can you show the difference in the
radar speeds between your two shotguns
thank you yeah I want to see how that
this will be our final four before
exhibition on this stream we appreciate
everybody who's sounding off in chat
those of you who are subscribing please
know that every subscription to our chat
on our twitch channel benefits the
Bungie foundation so we're not
monetizing the feedback loop as much as
we are I don't know consider it an
internet and put twitch Brian twitch
front which Brian
that wasn't a sales pitch that was just
us letting you know that we're taking
your money and putting it to a good use
basically expect all male a recharged
mods because he really wants to use
ballistic slam a lot which is the male
ability for the new third path of a
Spectre looks like money doing that for
the faring hammer once think your soup
there are some hammers at people's faces
let's see on the screen here I like that
the ace of spades pointing right at
clods no no you're pretty much on the
line fire the whole time sorry Claude
ignore that sniper rifle reserves thanks
again for all those servers we're gonna
we're gonna take your hard-earned money
and we're gonna put it toward easing the
stress the distress and suffering of
children the in hospitals we put I pad
Zin their hands you know we give them
the healing power of video games when
they need it the most you know the
subject of healing power they're gonna
need it right now as we come back into
our final round of clash let's do the
radar check radar radar check radar
check
mmm-hmm faces matter yep
oh just have come back yes okay
oh oh but you got it back here all good
yeah but he didn't say bonk someone
gonna make a sound for the balk I want
to stop for the radar kill him and get
the hair back yeah so the way that works
too is after about six seconds your
hammers gonna explode it's a yeah box
looks like to pick it up he just went
okay but it's okay because he used the
bunch of melee mods to get his [ __ ]
today and his buddy saved his life and
he was able to pick up grandma so now
he's got something going yes he's got
enough ammo but he should probably go
out there you go he's like four boys by
the way he's got something yeah we did
give that a little bit up dammit [ __ ]
Wow curse of being yeah people can't aim
anymore the pressure so the probably is
a handful to give anything goes I'm
looking at me I'm terrible also got all
the stickies came up except ever needs
beating and it's something that we
continue to obviously continue to look
at in the future all right this is
enough a one and done
come on come on pick it up yeah yeah you
wanna lose that hold on to them hold on
to that hammer he did use his third
shotgun to successful yeah he's got the
high ground etiquette hey yeah we agree
on Oprah tag names on those it's no
prickly green beans on street
in the wrong hands this is in my hands I
would be awful in the right hands people
just make it look like special be like
oh I can totally run that no no you
can't don't even try it here we go chase
for a while here camera loses parent
yeah so and yes so the hammer is gone we
lost it and you imagine this is a load
out for someone in your developer
insights video if you're crazy right
this is a crazy little guard that heavy
anything yeah you know I mean he's all
close multis a brawl I think for me is
honestly the best you know I was it does
everything I've you're PvE play you have
your PvP play you have your objective
play you have your little point right
like it has everything
so people gambit where you have your
whole team like shouts to suit your job
I think is going to be a huge deal and
there is absolutely a place for it for
cosmos crazy through shotgun build when
you are trying to keep blockers away
from the points and things like that and
gamma and so like all these all these
things have rolled in time to use them
and you know there will be people who
run this NP and physically you can
arrange your team to have like we're
gonna have a triple shot gun guy defend
the bomb or whatever
the rest is they have to deal with that
there's a lotta way to make that easy
Wow you still got that off on them
I think he's learning its he showed that
graphic is also helpful right like hey
don't do this do that
so no pressure hey supers ready it's not
like there are a lot of people walking
not just a demonstration of combat or
two but also a demonstration of the
bungee play test culture it's not a kind
well you did good - that's a good time
pretty shoddy rise cometh right before
the fall
yeah so the way that super works too is
you have your right trigger attack is
basically a ground the ground slam that
sends off a stream of fire and that'll
set out you find guys you know I
shouldn't done that in the tornado oh
it's perfect we wanted to take it over
the top if you haven't noticed already
to be explicit about it if you run a
single special loadout you get two
rounds per spawn and your load in and if
you run a dual special loadout you get
one in each so the same number of
spawning same amount of spawning ammo oh
man that was not the corner to run
around no right the ammo he was talking
the metal support archetypes if for a
shotgun you'll get it's worth who kills
the only difference Trace record Oh
and yeah you bump into 40 huh okay 30
male just saw commenting chat saying oh
they're seeing a lot of melee kills not
seeing a whole bunch from grenades our
grenades inherently different in year
two so we did buff grenades but the
nature of grenades is a lot of times
about they're an opener and so I think
that's what we're seeing a lot of times
here is that people are using them to
open fights or to sort of supplement
their gameplay but yeah what we didn't
do is make them one one-shot kill roll
back to where you can just rely on a
grenade to clean up but you have to play
with your grenade to make it effective
so you come up quite a bit but they're
not back to one-shot kills they're not
back to the reason why I wore void Fang
vestments for three years
yep still sticking with most tired of
being crazy has a range alteration all
right
so that mechanic especially dropping
from a corpse probably poorly oh yeah
yeah I feel like this is actually
somewhat of a viable Lord I've you know
the loadouts this is an in development
build so you're seeing under the radar
screen you're seeing some text strings
that are obviously not final so that's
what we see in development before we're
finished and it's not September 4th yet
so pardon our dust it is coming out
quickly yeah we are less than one month
from the beginning of more stadium and
even closer to the arrival of these
changes that's right we the things that
we're looking at right now not these
weapons not this map but
now the mom the sandbox changed oh
there's a hill grenade whoops oh no
floating orb their enemy bring down a
hillock and Abe oh that's how we do it
that's it
when you see one of those on the
opposing team you can actually still
destroy them all so he destroyed it
sound a lot of guys over fields yeah
so this elevator that they're standing
right here underneath when it comes down
to I might not want to be stormcaller
has he got a WoW waking a man Wow
swinging out I appreciate that I would
love to see
I stopped working on board possibly
funnies recently I've actually got it
supermodel ever gave a monster 2000 why
is my radar showing glowing red red boom
never mind boom of a moment here it
gives people right and they were on day
28
no one Wesley preload force against the
rock every player of Destiny is going to
notice some of these changes starting to
take effect the the weapon balance away
the the nuclear on the way to why not
behave will arrive mines will not be
there yet they come in these notes
release the slots will be you'll just
have nothing to put into this platform
no we will we have rearranged your
year-long weapons as well so you will
have stuff to put into them slots will
be there Greg yes the final week of year
one is going to be fast a little weird
we're going to have the new weapons
so are you gonna be able to run away the
widow will kind of ease into this
actually I'll get you out there and
you'll be able to play with this thing
get worried and I kill them and some new
an interesting combination take your
time
hey but I can punch people
bounce it out don't do all the weapons
that are yeah but I kind of like because
possible when it became too much
abilities not enough gunplay worth
noting whatever damage type you decide
to live with so your energy weapon when
you mod them go the rotating three-shot
bursts on burning ball that's the big
fire frying all sorts of orbs give a lot
more super energy after drunk 25 or will
we ever see a one shot I have no the
lanes well like the
who want to see that sort thomna just
makes things feel so much more dynamic
again I / lanes are gonna be tricky
you can't run them Gregor's lady holding
the flames like that snipers they can
hold Elaine Scarry better and now that
complain about because the sniper is
back really see it to hold those lanes
now finally are you going to observe
that sniper kill guys are you only going
to talk about us no that's not how I
play I've never been that type of sniper
like go out what I want to be on and
fire I'm not going to do the dragon fire
right and that's what I believe I
believe there won't be and the old
leaves a couple times
yes I think you know watching this I
hope that I hope chatting those at home
can get a sense for like imagine what it
would look like a good player right
there are still a lot of lingering
questions people want to see better
Devils in action a little bit more than
they have people talking about all the
shoulder charge mechanics in B to gain
an AoE is with them resolve it so they
have an explosion when you hit doesn't
one-shot the first guy yep but so tag if
you Charlie's gonna be originally Reaper
more than one version of a weapon
obviously now the collections will allow
you to sort of look across your riches
and understand which weapons that you
have but if you get a weapon that I love
that you think it's a god role or if you
want to have Oh several variations of
the river comes we have 500 total vault
follows now yeah I can get rid of most
of my craft now and the things that
we're now these roses on stream today
you know there's about 10 kills that
remain in this exhibition match you know
we're leaving for your discovery
you know player discovery understandable
doing it the changes impact their own
fighting style is an important one let's
do it it yeah we try to set your
expectations without completely giving
away the whole shop and August 28th will
be an interesting moment for people to
kind of come out and say here's not
likely differently now no and to your
point Josh that will change over time if
you change September 4th it'll change as
people discover each other it'll change
as people react to the shifting meta
start a figure out of the minds they
like and what they want to pair them
with there's so much to think about now
in a game
I mean there's gonna be a meta but I
mean there's a lot more variety with the
healing power minutes of an opposing
teams well of radiance you can't just
run in there and start punching guys
yeah that's another thing I know you're
not gonna get through that rift that one
one last chance to show off your
favorite moves don't forget to reload
after you're killing these fades that
the echoes here for me you just felt
like you just didn't have it I was like
my punching needs to be solid and now
they felt the we could find them
still be this is well and match complete
well playing no yeah there's a lot to
digest man it's gonna be fast this is
all gonna carry over to to IDE
yes we have to see that there's a little
there's so many changes we have to see
how that affects PDP I mean time to kill
across the board is so fast and you
definitely wanna there's no doubt about
that it's moving there's gonna be a lot
of balance in terms of things that you
used to do at the start of d2 that I'm
not gonna be I can already see I'm not
gonna be as effective with this no
matter and that's fine I'm saying like
you said people are going to find out
the most effective things I go liable
I'm still worried about that you've shot
your veil there thank you oh I know I
know guys there oh I know that people
can mess with it but I just like the
fact that something that stupid is an
option to fight of snipers and all the
right hands that are not mine oh that
the whole match if someone is very good
at closing distance and locating corners
and still down on top of that like even
though they're saying that you know the
MOU will deplete because you're kind of
going through the same reserve but now
that they've added you know special
drops on death you know that's like
literally getting Powerball it's out for
a shot good you know I mean it's a way
to keep it going though which is you
don't get much so you've got to be in
the mix or some way to grab it so I mean
sniping is gonna be harder to continue
to do which is you know I guess fair to
a point but yeah
shotguns mean those you'll if you get
somebody legal with them it'll be wrong
man oh so what your thoughts have the of
the meta that you see I mean three tap
pulse rifles the hain it's just like
even the primaries are hitting solids
which is I feel just a little crisper
that Lo is terrifying
oh it's carries house oh man that that
thing one you man like a competitive
group of four all running with that oh I
mean it's already gonna be the things
gonna be required for information and
that's yeah he said he had an
information build sword for peeking
around corners the bow to look through
walls you just I mean
communications huge in a way if you have
more info than the other team than the
holy crap that's quite the advantage on
top of the hunter new subclass Wraith
already going invisible remember but
that person kills that is going to be
scare hunters I don't want to hear
anything about complaints I could
already visualize some builds that are
gonna be sick oh man yeah this is this
is interesting the supers all look cool
they're looking unique we haven't suit
we need the old one so most of the new
ones yeah Titan missile is it's quicker
than I thought it was from a thirties
when you're looking at them like when it
looked as he was guiding and it looked
fairly slow before in the first video I
feel like they sped it up because before
it looked like almost a drone flying
around it felt slower this one yeah it's
like it's got a purpose and like if I'm
covering what is the stupid map from d1
that came over that has an s esteem to
it yes I don't you talk them out and it
has them the the B point is a little let
it yeah it's on this little platform
kind of flow together like that one if
you jump from the outside and you like
jumped up in the air and then did your
missile just like like they could fly
corners or
come from be like get a big fly over the
mountain towards a for example you just
fly in the tunnel to a and just go Pam
ladies yeah there's a lot of there's a
lot of options and I like the variety
and I think that's something that's
needed if the variety is relatively
balanced which I know it's not all gonna
be perfect
uh but if it gives it's not just like
the same six things coming at you right
it's 18 different things that might be
coming at you on top of snipers and
fusion rifles we didn't even see one
fusion rifle it's like that one's still
in progress but I haven't seen fusion
rifles ya know EJ loves those things
yeah there's a lot they like they like
they say about I was saying like again I
I know you laugh but I really want to
see chronologies I really know the one
like the special grenade launcher is
like the single concussive yes you could
put that on like a control point or
something and then switch over to a
kinetic like some three triple taps or
something like you you know it's gonna
work no I mean I think excited for a
while man I've been on my brain but let
let lets get to the questions for you
hey this is the Yvonne sistene arm relax
how're you feeling I need your armor uh
it's definitely better because we
finally saw a few perks in there we
hadn't seen squat
they had sniper and sword ammo
I'm gonna have to go back and just
literally like frame by frame a couple
things just to see him mm-hmm
but I'm talking about Sarika team come
sir no well no coach who are you gonna
say no no just doubling on you thought
just as far as like mama we also they
eat they talked about with armor you
know certain things to spec recharge up
to what is it 60% he said yeah so the
mods for like the melee he said was like
60% so maybe if you went same mod on all
five pieces you could have like twelve
percent on each yeah it's it's good
that's interesting
I know
would do something but I thought to be
honest I thought they were just gonna
simply simplify it like the one oh you
know you know the basics that do you
wanna have you know faster melee speed
or you know more ammo with shotguns when
this is on but it still seems like just
attach step further you know I thought I
thought that what I heard I didn't think
they would even do that I'm saying
certain things especially with the the
recharge speed and grenades me lately
and stuff like that so that that to me
was a pleasant surprise is it
groundbreaking to the ultimate d2 stuff
that we all we all wanted to have MMO
sensibilities no but I didn't think they
would even do this you know say so I'm
like okay you know so that's why I was
curious about you because I know this is
a very sore subject with you no yeah no
I was like from what I can see in little
pieces I'm getting back to d1 which is
kind of what we want but I still would
like more of an evolution yeah I'd like
to see set bonuses I'll never get or at
least I won't for a while I know that
I'll guess I've kind of accepted it at
least the fact that ARMA will have an
effect now is good so is it just back to
d1 it seems like it is it gonna be
anything substantially new I don't know
master worked armor is a thing currently
they have not mentioned that at all and
exotic armor is not gonna be master
worked which is kind of aggravating and
I don't know why so there are some
pieces and like they're so focused on
the weapons they haven't like completely
done armor I guess is my feel right so
that's kind of me so far like I like the
fact that perks are gonna be there cuz
right and then at least it's like I look
like it you know - helmets they're the
same be like oh this is better don't my
other one like there's actually a reason
it's not just like this is the same crap
over and over so the robot I like are
good and there's two different two
different roles which kind of back to
how it should be so it's getting better
I just like to see them I think this is
back to d1 I'd like to see them continue
to evolve it yeah absolutely that's me
at least done that nice this is positive
I mean you've gotten I still wish they
slowed down actually moving things
around within weapon slots like I feel I
still feel like they didn't show the
process you know I'm saying they're just
like I'm gonna do someone I know so fast
as far as you know between the primary
ammo and the energy slash secondary ammo
I mean weapons stuff yeah I mean like I
just thought they're a little bit they
were in kind of like testing dev mode so
they're just moving breakdown of weapon
slots yeah they were kind of quicker we
obviously know the functionality is
there I just would have been like the
speed you know slow down but it's clear
I mean um
yeah I mean this this is game-changing
this is what a lot of the community has
been clamoring for so to see them do it
and like you said earlier give because
it's almost like information overload
let's be honest all this stuff so I
think which is a genius move is them
releasing this part the weapons stuff
before the release of forsaken this way
we kind of gradually get into it we
understand how the process is you know
have that week or two or whatever it is
so really okay this is how we play now
right because we start we mentally been
you know engrained with the old with the
new you know the old new system yeah so
yeah man I mean there's this this this
gonna be something and we're gonna see
the meta is going to change oh oh babe
for a little while then you'll have a
gambit stuff that's probably gonna have
its own thing but that's the point of
something cool about gambit and I half
the time forget it's even coming cuz I
don't it's not like it's been out there
for so long it's not just like slammed
in our face now I have the time for I
forgot about until I said it was like oh
yeah that shotgun building gambit to
take out those main enemies if that's
your one purpose to keep the bank open
you stand here yeah we'll have yeah
people will have specific roles yeah
absolutely well you put a warlock with
that healing crazy super and you get
towards the end and you're just in like
a curious mode and they you launch your
primeval and you just go Bam Bam Bam Bam
and I think that brings back again the
big worry it's like the builds are crazy
I think the big worry about gambit is
burning the best boss too fast
if the primeval pops and everybody goes
boom and it's that I'm like 5 seconds
then III don't envy them on balance
because stuff that breaks the game I
know I mean picture like just back off
and for people whisper it [ __ ] it over
like think about whisper a secondary
sniper or I mean somebody just stay in
the bed like you said there could be a
person that can their role is just with
the shotgun stay in the front defendants
this could be a person in the back
nothing but snipers you don't sit there
like it's gonna be it's gonna be so
because it they definitely baby they
know they know they've opened himself up
because they've even said it with some
of the Seekers like hey we might think
this might break the game he says I
think they said that one about one of
the earlier reveals of the new supers
and they were talking about warlocks the
comment got me hot one mm-hmm yeah the
game so they're being ballsy they're
going for it they're not you know
they're going against typical Bungie mo
right which is let's say let's get them
no no no you gotta credit them for that
like that is something at the end of the
day we've always complained they're too
conservative let's wait for the day
there and then you don't get a patch
from that maybe six months or something
you gonna be my yeah you know for more
forty six months and you just you know
like okay finally you know the main put
this whoa yeah if it's complete fast and
person people gonna be figuring things
out and it's exciting it at the same
time it is still exciting so interesting
I'm at one twenty two twenty four when
she's finishing that yeah hold the
finish that out I don't know what the
last four minutes is probably just wrap
up three that's all we have today thank
you so much Cosmo and Kevin for playing
guys and thank you so much
absolutely - uh these gentlemen for the
work that you've put into the game and
for taking a break from your honeymoon
to join us today and thanks for sitting
in the seats and talking about what you
do yeah
everybody's super excited about what
they're seeing we're we're very much
like playing it's very excited hope you
guys are too yeah and this was
definitely a stream that they were very
eager to do you know they came to us and
they said we put a lot of work into the
second year of destiny too we've changed
up time-to-kill we've changed up weapon
slots and ammunition and perks and mods
and a lot of the things that the
community has been talking to us for
some time and they were very eager to
get out here on stream and to show you
how this works so thank you for watching
and thank you for benefiting our
charitable efforts with your subs and to
summarize we're giving you more ways to
configure your guardian so it's a
reflection of how you want to fight
we're bringing back some of those hero
moments what else do we want to say
about year three interesting drops to
keep them yeah the meta from going stale
and keep things interesting for a long
time
okay very good well some of these
changes will arrive on October 28th when
we preload forsaken all players of death
August will be how that's two years the
resignations arrive on September 4th
when or stakin begins with a brand new
adventure we hope you'll join us for all
of these things in the meantime we will
see you at Gamescom we'll see you at PAX
we may even see you right back here on
stream and good luck in tryouts good
luck with your tribes yes you still have
several weeks left in the solstice of
heroes so we see hope we'll see you in
the towers for that so in celebration
with those new challenges those new ways
to decorate yourself that's all we have
to say today yeah all right thanks so
much for watching that's all we got to
see it probably do one one oh yeah oh
yeah the old one
all right we could talk about it so yeah
man I also want to say one thing - um I
gotta give a little credit with the mods
you know I like I like the direction you
know I'm not gonna say it's perfect it's
you know we got us we have to play but
um I was impressed
I was I was impressed with certain
things you know I didn't because one
thing we always gave them crime een
always killed him in d1 is that one
perks were uninteresting there were just
certain perks that would outweigh
outclassed others right yeah so when I
saw a perk for God likely to see a perk
like rangefinder back when I know like
that was one of their fears because
people used to go for that role you know
saying oh so now to see these
combinations come back and then let's I
mean again this is my I don't want to
know how you feel about it but with the
Mars did seem to be a lot of variety
there seemed to be a lot of variety
based on PvE or PvP play styles I didn't
see like stuff like you know crouched
and you know those wack perks where you
just like yeah there weren't wasted but
I would say variety wise for mods that
you pick no perks versus mods mods that
you pick there look to be about eight
nine maybe so there'd be a ton but the
right hurts paired with the mods you can
have like I got have a better Devils
that's PvE and a better Devils this PvP
I mean I know I didn't really see a home
I was a baby eight to ten I would say
right I thought the ones that we saw
seemed interesting yeah no I'm not
arguing that the ones there are not like
there's no fluff they're all like okay
like and they all are function that's
what I'm saying I hope over time with
like expansions maybe there at least one
or two new mods and so help build
varieties I'm with you on it that would
be dope that would be dope that would be
kind of a cool thing to be like hey
we've got a couple new mods coming this
one's gonna be against so-and-so or this
one's gonna add you know a couple ones
because like eight to ten mods you're
still gonna have most of the time I mean
if I don't play Icarus like jumping that
much that ones
it may not be for me some of those some
of those may be more PvE so you've got
the bosses the power powerful enemies so
like the orange bars so then you think
about okay what am I gonna use in PvE or
PvP like for different mods so I mean
that's where the I mean the perks and
the mods combined maybe a lot but the
actual mods themselves while shortened I
wish there were there hopefully they
bring some more overtime if there's like
the short of Elizabeth I saw I mean
there's the chance that we have not seen
all of them on yeah I mean yeah I see
your point though I see your point
yeah I mean I will say this oh my god
god bless you fault because you know
like you say like there's gonna be
things that people gonna run want to run
like you know PvE specific type better
devils and weapon loadouts and then
there's gonna be ones that are like
you're gonna get roles combined with
mods that are just gonna be like godly
in pvp so that's gonna be their votes
gonna be interesting because I know me
at least my habits I hold on you know
like it's gonna get you to point out
like we may be more slots in you know
per per character it take the whole dog
I don't know if that might be enough
they're like craziness with exotics and
Cray you don't roles and stuff like that
so fun time fun fun you know new world
problems to see oh yeah so I don't know
I mean what's your overall what you feel
you know when they got impressed me very
cautious to oh it's always a negative
side cuz I wouldn't say that's you but
you know I want to look in there and be
like urgh I want to know a little more I
want to see all this I want to see we
saw the one set of perk trees and that
was interesting because it's just
another tree of Port trees so it's just
one more basically but it's a whole new
super which is
so that's the point where I was kind of
wondering when you do the perk trees
like so if it's a whole new super you
only have one way to play that super you
don't have two different ways to play
that super see right point absolutely
absolutely so that's got one of those
when you I mean I'll give you
technically nine new supers but I mean
really two of them are the same that
play like slightly differently some will
have double grenades latent storm
collars this earth everything striker
mmm-hmm that's like you've got your
double grenade build and then you've got
a different you've got your two
different builds but they're both
striker now you just have a third perk
treat that just changes everything ups
and that's where I was hoping you could
have like super on the top super on the
bottom and have two and two so there
were more variety to the perk tree so
little things like that maybe they'll
add in time but I mean it's their way to
I mean I'm not sad that there are things
in there it's just if they're going to
make them equal it doesn't feel like
they are there's two ways to play the
old supers there's only one way to play
the new one mmm-hmm like no I get it I
think what we're talking about is an
overall probably arc towards d3 which is
I don't think I'll be able to implement
now which is kind of going back to you
know like how D 1 was when you had a
bubbler configure every single thing you
know me into builds that you want out of
all of them you know I mean so I get
that I completely get that and um I
don't know my gut tells me I don't think
we get that indeed I'd be shocked if
they're able to put that in at some
point during the lifespan of d2 bar arm
yeah we need that old-school you know
MMO style customer customization with
the perk bubbles per subclass to truly
configure it and truly play so I don't
think we're there yet but to me at least
them adding this is it that kind of like
a little band-aid for what we've been
complaining on as far as the subclasses
and stuff like that and yeah and I also
have even through that let's be honest
like a lot of that new stuff looks
really really cool I'm just copy that
and people gonna play we're all gonna
fluctuate the new stuff first that's
just how it's gonna go oh yeah they they
did say hey we're doing this with gold
and we do all the stuff we know you're
probably not gonna want to touch it
initially you're doing it to the new
stuff key
mind that we made some buffs and natural
I want just to not have stuff neglected
so you know you know we're getting there
okay it's all progress in the right
direction I'm not saying that in any way
like all of this seems positive I like
how the I like how master works are
evolving yeah do I think the ten levels
of a master work is kind of a way to
slow that down
I didn't know how I didn't know I don't
know I feel about that yeah enough to
see like I mean it does give you
something to spend glimmer on
occasionally which is normally like
nothing so I guess there's that but then
as you get into I want to know how hard
is it gonna be to get you know master
work orbs and stuff like that so some of
that stuff is just gonna have to play
out and see how it's balanced my
suggestion to anybody who's listening
don't mess to work anything too quickly
because there's gonna be a bunch of
rolls coming your way for a little while
so you're gonna have to wait a minute
and see unless you just get one that is
just epic but um some of that stuff's
gonna take a little while but I like at
least the fact that I mean for one
there's the different options cuz you
got the different roles it is so funny
just to go back and be like oh we're
gonna you know make sure your 10th
better it up your better levels has a
reason they never figured that out
without random roles and it's just I was
like that one just straight up you gotta
eat your words and be like they know it
they clogged up so why you would say
yeah so I mean that's kind of one of
those things that call him back to but
mostly overall I mean I just want to get
my hands on the game it's like we're
less than a month away more than 28 days
or whatever that is math wise and we get
a free of a one-week free crier to mess
around with weapons yeah that's gonna be
it's gonna be interesting yeah I like it
man listen I got sauce is going on at
the end of the day on my 4 or 5 salute
salute salute
I so load the missions not as terrible
but Calais solo on blue he's it's really
touching go go go right call yeah sorry
not Calais golf yeah yeah I wish should
have been golf Solomon Collins need to
get us
lighten sand that's a bungee I don't
think you actually could do that
I think people to manic because you have
to be inside but to man's as small as
you get but not really not that good
either but no so just soloing doll it's
like I like the way those feel I want
more of that type of stuff leveling up
the armor mm-hmm I like the way they did
some of those like these are little
teases that I want to see like you
wearing the full set you get orbs that's
a set bonus technically mm-hmm more of
that stuff like those are the type of
things that need to continue to evolve
and honestly I think with these
expansions as they go they're gonna be
like so maybe armor percocets maybe
that's in like the second one or PIN
number or something before what like
those are things to continue to evolve
later but they've got like there's
probably like a main project tied to
each expansion or annual pass release I
should say mm-hmm and those are the ones
I'll be curious to see but I mean since
January we've been doing this and it's
been quite the train to follow and I
think we're at a great place to say
would you recommend Forsaken to anyone
who was let down by anything in dusty
one yes you should pick it up yeah and
that's why I can phrase it if you
enjoyed d1 felt a little off on d2 I
think you're gonna be happy with what
they've done and is even more ways yeah
I completely agree this is this is the
time to come back you know I mean
they're really going out there way to
get back all the d1 sensibilities but
also that I don't feel talked about is
let's be honest um d1 stuff wasn't good
right and what I like is this is also
the evolution of certain things from d1
because I do like the fact that hey
we're not gonna open a [ __ ] because
there were some people I remember how I
used to be people would throw a fusion
army and walk away
there's no gunplay so they took me
they're finding their way to as far as
that bounce because as much as we
romanticize d1 there was still some
flaws oh no if there was the part of me
on the grenade stuff is like I don't
count on grenades for kills in PvP
basically
ever there a way to tickle people in
like kind of hurt yeah and then run in
but to me a grenade should have some
lethality sometimes I don't think hardly
any of them do
now there's careful with no I know and
that's why was like is it a balance of
like if it's more lethal as a longer
cool down time in PvP I don't I don't
know the answer and that's the thing I'd
love to be after ability spam and people
don't dis Corbino gunplay that used to
happen people would throw I say like
certain grenades remember fireballs bro
I know but I was also like with Viking
funeral he just throw that in a group
and tick tick tick tick tick it was over
it was no gunplay like I said I'm just
saying like I don't know what the
balance is but to me sometimes it's
annoying that a grenade that attaches to
your body what doesn't kill you when it
explodes twice on some of those I play a
lot I believe that it is for the most
cheapest feeling I'm telling you like it
felt like there's no skill and we
already know the magnetic nature of
those type of grenades you know in it
kind of like have the graves and that's
they always have a missus like like as
long as you go in the general direction
it will stick to you that character so I
in in in theory right in application if
you have a grenade it should in theory
should do more power but it's like what
time to kill being increased you know
it's it's a tough balance in that you
know I like it as a finish this isn't
getting me person I know you you want it
to be more than y'all's fair I get it
you know me I just I like it as a
finished or startup or or like someone's
running away you know I get it because
you know just I just feel it's a little
bit more fair specially with time to
kill me what it's gonna be now lay oh
it's pretty speedy yeah this is a good
one for debate but I are we going yeah
that's like it's it's like and I don't
know the answer cuz yeah I mean getting
spammed with those was annoying did I do
it - yes did I rely on those problems
yes it's like I totally understand that
reminds just like it is truly like the
think of a grenade in real life it's
terrifying it's lethal and that's what I
feel someone what do you want
the grenades yes but I was like if they
are that hard then you have to avoid the
spam so then is it too long and that's
what it's like that's why I don't have
the answer and that's really should
admit that they lee sooman I respect
that
I don't know I don't I don't have the
answer but some sometimes for me it's
like the one the one hit the shoulder
charge like the to hit melee those are
back to feeling and you were okay with
those oh yeah because the problem with
the engagements in close-quarter Dilys
max fell flat vest man it's throughout
week it did not feel good right at the
end of the day if we're that close
engaging you know and we've already kind
of shot each other the way and in fact
it still tapped it three melee hit know
that that's clumsy I completely agree
with you two is in my opinion fair yeah
Bam Bam like so here's an example that
map they were just playing twice there
seemed to be like an upper raised area
with two rooms across a bridge right so
say you're on one side you throw a
tripmine behind somebody it has a second
it arms it explodes still not killing
people I don't want that I tell you no I
was like that's that's the I'm just
trying to get clarify because that's not
a fusion grenade that's a thrill arm hit
bam like there's a delay to its function
Joe I don't think I know that's what
it's like I don't have the answer
sometimes to me it's just it feels like
shoulder charge just sucks before it did
so it was just you run up bam you're
like and then I would die cuz they're
shooting you as you run and then you
still have to go slap him twice and it
was never enough so this that's a good
change back to what I think it should be
do I have the answer for grenades no but
for me do they feel right now
but that's still work-in-progress so
laughs again lots of changes in good
directions we will absolutely no well 53
years oh yeah we have long point today I
should actually flash like put a like a
little like lime through it and see if I
could do like a tape cymbal and do one
over the cover but yeah so I'm actually
working with tweaks on my finally it's
been a little long on my logo so he's
just we've been waiting well I was at a
town meeting only waiting I little
cheesy went down there but now it's uh
it's getting close he's organized he's
starting to finalize it tonight but he
lost all of his info so he had a crash
and he told me that like a couple days
after I got back and I was getting ready
to finish tweaks with him so I was like
few extra weeks in the making so next
week we'll have something sitting next
to your little uh ninja night there nice
nice time wait a minute I'm late gotta
be good sell well yeah I think this will
be a good place to wrap it up so
hopefully you guys enjoy I know we had
some and twitch stream there for a
little while I think most I guess I'm
trickled off as we've stopped but thank
you guys for tuning in and this will be
on my youtube and you'll throw it on
yours as well so definitely follow Lord
kognito
Cervantes Twitter twitch YouTube iron
Lords podcast tick network hate us on
everything yes please do finally
everywhere honest every way so what
we're doing trying to make the content
you guys and just generate good healthy
discussion you know and this is why I do
it my boy bouncers we always have those
those deep discussions that turn in a
long point but it's fun it's it's good
for you know talking about what's
happening adapt to the getting seen both
sides it you know fence even with stuff
that he made that agree with me and I
mean but it's always good to hear the
other side so that kind of stuff always
like that type of engagement
yeah I mean that's kind of thing it's
like we sometimes have different points
but it's kind of thing I would told my
wife feels like a I'm gonna be on the
podcast she's like should like you
should be on there at some point she's
like uh what's your opinion on this
she's like I have nothing I was like
it'd be hilarious just have a run he
knows absolutely nothing the opinions
that a casual gamer she's like I'm not
even
dojo yeah so thank you guys follow us
like the video if you do enjoy them
leave comments if you guys want to see
us end up anything in our next
flashpoint we'll look at the table and
honestly just see if it merits one this
Friday maybe it will maybe it won't
maybe try maybe a cover level but there
probably be no need to be redundant but
if there's way more new stuff that they
didn't talk about yeah a little so it
will make that I will say yeah so as
always follow us on Twitter that's
usually is where you get the updates if
we're going to alive but before we get
to two hours let's go to wrap this thing
up so I got a render it and upload it
then I still got other videos to do but
you know enjoy your grind Soulstice is
fun it's long for something if you're
going for all three good luck good luck
with that
yeah but for the rest of you guys thank
you for tuning in and do you want to do
sign ups we kind of got them covered
have a good one peace